Hello, my name is Veronica Kassova. I live in Edinburgh and I just graduated with a master's in psychology of mental health. Marion recommended me the Clinical Psychologist Collective when I was networking on LinkedIn and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others,
你好，我叫维罗妮卡·卡索娃。我住在爱丁堡，刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。当我在领英上建立人脉时，玛丽安向我推荐了“临床心理学家集体”（Clinical Psychologist Collective），我必须说我非常喜欢它。它是独一无二的。它就像是一扇窗，让我们得以窥见那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。这些故事独特、真诚，充满了只有个人叙事才能揭示的那种无形的智慧。在我最珍视的故事中，一个共同的主题是不仅要善待他人，
but with myself too. Also, not fixating on becoming a psychologist, but enjoying life, grow, and the final results will come as a by-product. Marian, thank you for taking the time to collate all the stories. The book is a true gem and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you. We don't talk about this enough, but travelling can shape a psychologist just as much as studying or supervision. Because when you backpack, get lost, meet strangers, experience joy and uncertainty. You build empathy, perspective, flexibility and the kind of emotional intelligence you often just can't learn in a classroom. So today, we are asking, what if the time you spend out
也要善待自己。此外，不要执着于成为心理学家，而是要享受生活、成长，最终的结果会作为副产品自然到来。玛丽安，感谢你花时间整理这些故事。这本书是一块真正的瑰宝，我认为每一位有抱负的心理学家都应该在书架上放一本。谢谢。我们对这个话题讨论得还不够，但旅行对心理学家的塑造作用，丝毫不亚于学习或督导。因为当你背起行囊，迷路，结识陌生人，体验快乐与不确定性时，你建立起了同理心、视角、灵活性以及那种通常在课堂上学不到的情商。所以今天，我们要问的是，如果你花时间去
there in the world is not a detour from psychology, but one of the best trainings you'll ever have? Hope you'll love it. If you do, like and subscribe for more. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist and I'm joined here by the very intrepid Ben. Hi Ben, welcome Malong. Hi Maryan, thanks very much for having me. I've been very excited to do this ever since you first got in touch. Oh well yeah thank you for responding to my emails because this is how this came about right so you is it is it okay to say which country you're currently in Ben? Yeah absolutely yeah I'm currently in Chile
外面的世界看看，这难道不是心理学道路上的弯路，而是你所能接受的最好的训练之一吗？希望你会喜欢。如果喜欢，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，欢迎来到“有抱负的心理学家播客”。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，今天和我在一起的是非常勇敢的本。嗨，本，欢迎来到这里。嗨，玛丽安，非常感谢你的邀请。自从你第一次联系我，我就一直很兴奋能参加这个节目。哦，好的，谢谢你回复我的邮件，因为这就是这个节目的由来，对吧？那么，本，可以说你目前在哪个国家吗？是的，当然可以，我目前在智利，
travelling with my partner. Amazing and yeah like I said you are intrepid I think when I spoke to to you to plan the episode. You were in, were you in Canada? Have I imagined that? I was, yeah. We've been in Canada for the past year and a quarter-ish. We'll talk a little bit more about what I've been up to there, but went back to the UK for a few weeks and then came further south to escape for the freezing cold winter. And the idea of our episode really is to think about how travel can enrich you as an aspiring or qualified psychologist. And how it might not be, I guess, that narrative of I want to get there as soon as I can get there. I want to be qualified by the time I'm 27 or I want to get there before I'm 30. And actually how we might be able to release the pressure of that and think about what we might learn along the way.
和我的伴侣一起旅行。太棒了，正如我所说，你很勇敢。我想当我为了策划这期节目和你交谈时，你是在加拿大吗？是我记错了吗？是的，我确实在。过去一年多一点的时间里我们都在加拿大。我们会多聊聊我在那里的经历，但后来回英国待了几周，然后又向南走，为了躲避严寒的冬天。我们这期节目的初衷其实是思考旅行如何能丰富你作为一名有抱负或合格的心理学家的经历。以及它可能不像那种“我想尽快到达终点”的叙事。我想在27岁时获得资格，或者我想在30岁之前达到目标。实际上，我们该如何释放这种压力，思考我们在旅途中能学到什么。
If we don't go directly, you know, to pass go, collect 200 pounds to quote monopoly. But, you know, what we might learn about ourselves, what we might learn about the world, what we might learn about others and how some of the experiences we have when we're travelling will help us to bolster life when it unfolds later what are your thoughts around that then yeah absolutely i feel that pressure as well as there's any aspiring psychologist because the goal is the doctorate and then you feel like maybe once you get up to training that's your path all lined up even if you're not quite there yet um because it can feel a little bit muddy to get there so people often like myself want to rush through that um and i've
如果我们不直接走捷径，你知道，就像大富翁游戏里那样，直接通过起点领取200英镑。但是，我们能从中学到关于自己、关于世界、关于他人的什么，以及我们在旅行中的一些经历将如何帮助我们在未来生活展开时支撑我们？你对此有什么看法，本？是的，绝对。作为任何一个有抱负的心理学家，我也感受到了那种压力，因为目标是博士学位，然后你会觉得一旦你进入培训，你的道路就铺好了，即使你还没完全达到那个阶段。嗯，因为到达那里的过程可能会让人感觉有点模糊，所以人们通常像我一样想要匆忙完成它，而且我
felt that pressure whilst travelling as well almost looking far too and far into the future and constantly thinking about what i'm going to do when i get home and forgetting what am i doing just now because you know i'm in this beautiful place and i've got all this free time to meet new people and experience new things and reflect on that and just take my time which is something i'm getting better at at the moment. And I'm probably in the most comfortable place I've ever been with not rushing and just taking a moment to absorb what's happening to me just now. So it really is an exercise in mindfulness, isn't it, of enjoying where you're at right now and maybe appreciating that without then feeling like you need to jump ahead to the next step, the next thing. So
在旅行时也感受到了那种压力，几乎总是看得太远，太关注未来，不断思考回家后要做什么，而忘记了现在正在做什么。因为你知道，我身处这个美丽的地方，我有这么多空闲时间去结识新朋友，体验新事物，并对此进行反思，慢慢来，这是我目前正在进步的地方。我可能正处于我所经历过的最舒适的状态，不再匆忙，只是花点时间去吸收现在发生在我身上的一切。所以这确实是一种正念练习，不是吗？享受你当下的处境，也许在欣赏它的同时，而不觉得你需要跳到下一步，下一件事。所以
it's not holding yourself accountable. Is there anyone holding you accountable? So I know that my mum was very keen for me to become a doctor. And if I'd had this protracted period of time, she might have been able to. When are you progressing your career? Or are you literally just living to your own timeline then? Yeah, I don't think I've got any pressure from family or friends or anything like that, which I'm extremely grateful for. And I'm a little bit later in coming to psychology as well. You know, I did an engineering degree out of school and men spent my 20s doing various kind of unrelated jobs. I'm 30 years old just now at time of filming. And I've not long finished my conversion degree. But my parents have always very much been of the mindset that
这不是让你承担责任。有人在监督你吗？我知道我妈妈非常希望我成为一名医生。如果我有一段这么长的时间，她可能已经能够说：“你什么时候在推进你的职业生涯？”或者你真的只是按照自己的时间表生活吗？是的，我不认为我来自家人或朋友的压力，对此我非常感激。而且我进入心理学领域也比较晚。你知道，我大学读的是工程学，20多岁时做过各种不相关的工作。拍摄时我刚好30岁。我刚完成转换课程没多久。但我的父母一直持有的心态是，
as long as I'm enjoying what I'm doing and fulfilled, it's irrelevant how I'm doing that, which I feel very grateful for because I don't feel any pressure externally. I've got that intrinsic pressure but from the outside, I feel very comfortable that I don't need to do anything for the service of anyone else. Good, good. I'm pleased to hear it. And it might be a whole other episode, like thinking about moving from engineering to psychology, but we'll try and stick to travel. But that sounds fascinating as well. And, you know, I think when we first met, it was because you'd requested a psychology guide and you told me what your pressing concern was. And I seem to remember it was along the lines of how can I kind of get some relevant experience when I'm not, when I'm not in the UK, so that I can kind of try and keep moving along a little bit. How have you found that element or have you had to give yourself permission to just travel? A little bit of both, actually. So initially when we decided to travel to Canada, the initial plan was to perhaps do a bit of backpacking for a few months.
只要我做的事情让我快乐且感到充实，我怎么做并不重要，对此我感到非常感激，因为我没有感受到任何外部压力。我有那种内在的压力，但从外部来看，我感到非常自在，不需要为了服务于任何人而做任何事。很好，很高兴听到这些。从工程学转向心理学可能又是另一期节目的话题了，但我们尽量坚持谈论旅行。但这听起来也很迷人。而且，我想我们第一次见面是因为你申请了一份心理学指南，你告诉我你最紧迫的担忧是什么。我记得大概是关于“当我不在英国时，我该如何获得一些相关经验，以便我能保持一点进步”。你是如何看待这一点的，或者你是否不得不给自己许可去单纯地旅行？两者都有，其实。所以最初当我们决定去加拿大旅行时，最初的计划是也许做几个月的背包客，
then find maybe a location we liked or a job that suited both of our career paths and then stay in one fixed location for a year to a year and a half and get that career progression. But then as time went on and sort of realization just how big the place was that we wanted to travel across, started to realize it was perhaps impractical and maybe not what we actually wanted out of it the most between the career progression and experience of traveling. So we decided to park that and focus on the backpacking side of it. But on the flip side, I did take on a voluntary research role whilst we were travelling, which was only three to five hours a week. So it was kind of perfect. You know, I could do that on a little fixed time slot that I'd set aside each week
然后找一个我们喜欢的地点，或者一份适合我们两人职业道路的工作，然后在一个固定的地点待上一到一年半，获得职业晋升。但随着时间的推移，意识到我们想要穿越的地方有多大，开始意识到这可能不切实际，也许不是我们在职业晋升和旅行体验之间最想要的。所以我们决定搁置那个计划，专注于背包旅行。但另一方面，我在旅行期间确实承担了一个志愿研究角色，每周只有三到五个小时。所以这很完美。你知道，我可以在每周预留的一个固定时间段内完成它，
and get to gain that experience while not having to focus on it and not having to be the centre of my, you know, thoughts. Yeah, absolutely. So have you had, to kind of have jobs in the UK to be able to fund your travel or are you kind of working in non-relevant roles as you go along um a little bit of both so i was working as a mental health support worker for a charity for three years um and then i did a part-time conversion degree which i actually did the final year of whilst we were travelling but after saving up um some money but not that much because initially our plan was to have enough money to get by for a few months We actually signed up for a work exchange program, which we've used in the past in other countries, called Workaway, which is fantastic.
并获得那种经验，而不必专注于它，也不必让它成为我思想的中心。是的，绝对。那么，为了资助你的旅行，你是否必须在英国找工作，或者你是在旅途中从事一些不相关的工作？嗯，两者都有。我曾为一家慈善机构担任心理健康支持工作者三年，然后我修读了一个非全日制转换学位，我实际上是在旅行期间完成了最后一年。但在存了一些钱之后，虽然没存多少，因为最初我们的计划是存够几个月的生活费。我们实际上报名参加了一个工作交换项目，我们过去在其他国家用过，叫Workaway，非常棒。
So essentially the deal tends to be you work between 20 and 25 hours per week for someone, and that could be doing anything from helping them do up their kitchen, gardening. Maybe it's somebody who's trying to become self-sustaining, has a little bit of land, child care, whatever. And in exchange, you get accommodation and all of your food. So you're not earning, but you get to situate yourself in that place for a long time without spending anything. And we've had some really unique opportunities through that as well. We got to volunteer at a dementia social club in British Columbia in Canada. So that just came up and it was absolutely perfect. I got to get a little bit additional experience and the travel experience all compacted into one.
所以本质上，协议通常是你每周为某人工作20到25个小时，这可能包括从帮他们装修厨房、园艺到任何事情。也许是某人试图变得自给自足，有一小块土地，照顾孩子，等等。作为交换，你获得住宿和所有的食物。所以你没有收入，但你可以在那个地方待很长时间而不用花钱。我们也通过那个项目获得了一些非常独特的机会。我们在加拿大不列颠哥伦比亚省的一家痴呆症社交俱乐部做志愿者。所以那个机会刚好出现，非常完美。我获得了一点额外的经验，并将旅行体验合二为一。
So, yeah, that was amazing. Work away. I will make sure that I link to them in the description and the show notes because that sounds amazing. I would have, I would have loved that actually. And I was thinking about how I did it. So I've travelled relatively extensively and I, my journey only really started after I'd done my undergraduate degree. So I graduated when I was 21 and then it was always the plan because my friend and I had always planned it that way that we'd, we'd save us. up. So we'd work our fingers to the bone so that we could go away and not work for six months and so that our, you know, travel insurance was paid for all of the flights, all of that jazz. And so that's what we did. So from the summer of 20, no, I've got the, when is it, 90, no, 2002, that's right. Until February 2003, I worked doing home care and then I worked doing temping and in call centres, literally trying to work every minute that God sent me to earn as much money as I could so that I could do that. And I did. And then by the time I got
所以，是的，那太棒了。Workaway。我一定会确保在描述和节目笔记中提供他们的链接，因为这听起来太棒了。我其实会很喜欢那个。我在想我是怎么做的。所以我旅行得比较多，我的旅程真正开始是在我本科毕业之后。所以我21岁毕业，然后计划一直都是这样，因为我和我的朋友一直那样计划，我们会存钱。所以我们会拼命工作，这样我们就可以离开，六个月不用工作，这样我们的旅行保险、所有的机票、所有那些杂费都付清了。所以这就是我们所做的。所以从2002年的夏天，不，我记错了，什么时候，90，不，2002年，没错。直到2003年2月，我做家庭护理，然后做临时工和呼叫中心工作，真的试图利用上帝赐予我的每一分钟去赚尽可能多的钱，这样我就可以那样做。我做到了。然后当我
back from six months around the world, which just to kind of very briefly go over what that looked like, it was Thailand for six weeks, Australia for 10 weeks, New Zealand for three weeks, I think Fiji for just 24 hours in and out and then San Diego and L.A. for a week. Yeah, scary experiences at the L.A. station where we were. Wow. And then from there it was Mexico for six weeks. And it's very quickly how six months. breaks down but by the time I got home in August 2003 you know but going via spending my 22nd birthday swimming with wild dolphins in New Zealand and then going out and whale watching like you know these are just not the sort of experiences I would have had if I had been an aspiring site like in Milton Keynes right not too many whales can be found in Milton Keynes but like by the
从六个月的环球旅行回来时，简单回顾一下那是什么样子，那是泰国六周，澳大利亚10周，新西兰三周，我想斐济只待了24小时，然后圣地亚哥和洛杉矶待了一周。是的，在洛杉矶车站有可怕的经历。哇。然后从那里是墨西哥六周。六个月很快就过去了，但当我2003年8月回家时，你知道，在去新西兰和野生海豚一起游泳度过我22岁生日，然后去观鲸之后，你知道，这些不是如果我像在米尔顿凯恩斯那样做一个有抱负的心理学家会有的经历，对吧？在米尔顿凯恩斯找不到太多鲸鱼，但当我
time I got home I literally had about I don't know, 20 quid in my bank account. I was going through on fumes. And I remember going back in to see my colleagues. I went shopping probably a couple of days after I got back. I went in to see my old colleagues and that was like on a Thursday or a Friday where I'd been doing my temping. And the manager said, okay, Marianne, you've had your fun now. Like you're back. Do you want to come and work for a starting Monday? And I was like, okay, yes, because I need some money and then you know then I was salaried so yeah I needed the money right but yeah I've definitely been intrepid as an aspiring psych since then as well but
回家时，我的银行账户里大概只有20英镑。我几乎耗尽了所有积蓄。我记得回去看我的同事。我回来后大概几天就去购物了。我去看了我的老同事，那是在我做临时工的周四或周五。经理说，好了，玛丽安，你现在玩够了。你回来了。你想从周一开始工作吗？我说，好的，是的，因为我需要钱，然后你知道，我拿薪水了，所以是的，我需要钱，对吧？但自从那时起，作为一名有抱负的心理学家，我也绝对很勇敢，但
it sounds like you definitely are looking for what opportunities you can learn along the way yeah absolutely I mean there's no harm in getting as much out of it as you can and I think like I mentioned that work away platform is brilliant because there are you know we've seen lots of other opportunities that might be sort of indirectly or directly related to the skills a later need if I do get onto training etc so yeah it's nice to be able to do that but I am definitely um aware of the fact that I know I'm sometimes very goal focused and I'm just trying to slow down a little bit and enjoy it a little bit more because I always say to myself you know in 30 years time am I going to look
听起来你确实在寻找旅途中可以学到的机会。是的，绝对。我的意思是，尽可能多地从中获得收获并没有什么坏处，而且我认为就像我提到的，Workaway平台很棒，因为我们看到了很多其他机会，如果我真的进入培训等，这些机会可能与我以后需要的技能间接或直接相关。所以是的，能做到这一点很好，但我绝对意识到这样一个事实：我知道我有时非常注重目标，我只是试图放慢一点速度，多享受一点，因为我总是对自己说，你知道，30年后，我会回头看
back and say, I wish I travelled less or I wish I travelled more. So yeah, I know what mine would be. Is your partner striving for a career as well or just seeing how life unfolds? Yes, but she's in a similar mindset and she works in nature conservation. It's a little bit of a different career path. You know, lots of different jobs, short-term contracts with everything. It's sort of underfunded charity organisations, etc. So there's maybe a little bit of a less of a rush or pressure for her to sort of take a next step which is nice because that helps that helps me level out a little bit and try to appreciate the
并说，我希望我少旅行一点，还是希望我多旅行一点？所以是的，我知道我的答案会是什么。你的伴侣也在追求职业生涯，还是只是顺其自然？是的，但她的心态也差不多，她在自然保护领域工作。这是一个有点不同的职业道路。你知道，很多不同的工作，各种短期合同。这是一种资金不足的慈善组织，等等。所以她可能没有那么大的紧迫感或压力去采取下一步行动，这很好，因为这有助于我稍微平衡一下，并尝试欣赏
pace that she's taking into that yeah sounds like a really nice companion like that you you have such similar values and definitely seems to be kind of a mantra that life is for living right yeah i just feel very blessed in that regard yeah have you had a when you look back on kind of of civil travels have you had some really standout memories where you're just like god this is this is incredible like how how lucky am i yeah one of them was very recently in canada actually um so through the work away platform we got a couple of months of paid work um on an island on the northwest as it goes um and there's a total pain to get there you either fly or for half the price you take a 17-hour ferry, which also has a seven-hour ferry, the other side of it.
她采取的节奏。是的，听起来是一个非常好的伴侣，你们有如此相似的价值观，而且这绝对似乎是一个“生活就是为了活着”的口头禅，对吧？是的，在这方面我感到非常幸运。当你回顾你的旅行时，你有没有一些非常突出的记忆，让你觉得“天哪，这太不可思议了，我有多幸运”？是的，其中一个最近在加拿大，其实。通过Workaway平台，我们在西北部的一个岛上获得了几个月的带薪工作。去那里真是个麻烦，你要么坐飞机，要么为了省一半的钱，坐17小时的渡轮，另一边还有七小时的渡轮。
So we took that as a cheaper option, and everybody told us it was stunning. And I'm on this ferry, which is almost taken for convenience in terms of price, and lost count of the amount of whales that we saw on this journey, and the scenery was just like nothing I'd ever seen, you know, during a lot of years of travel. It was just absolutely spectacular. And I was sat on this ferry, you know, just blow. away and thinking you know there's cruises that come up this area and you'll pay thousands of thousands of pounds to come and do this and I've paid basically
所以我们选择了那个更便宜的选项，每个人都告诉我们那里美极了。我在那艘渡轮上，这几乎是为了价格方便而选择的，我数不清我们在这次旅程中看到了多少鲸鱼，风景简直是我多年旅行中从未见过的。这绝对是壮观的。我坐在那艘渡轮上，你知道，简直被震撼了，心想，你知道，有游轮会来这个地区，你会花成千上万英镑来做这件事，而我只付了
the equivalent of a hundred quid for a couple of day of the trial and just one of the best experiences I've ever had and it was yeah totally unexpected yeah I hear you and I would have gone for the ferry as well because I think the difference is if you're just on a two-week holiday you're thinking I don't want to necessarily spend you know, 25 hours or whatever, you know, just on this bit of journey. Whereas I think what happens when you have an extended time away is that the journey becomes quite part of the experience in itself, doesn't it? Like I think back to the day that I spent trying to sleep in the doorway of a shop at Mexico City airport where the whole airport was then shut down due to
相当于一百英镑的费用，这是我经历过的最好的体验之一，而且是的，完全出乎意料。是的，我明白你的意思，我也会选择渡轮，因为我认为区别在于，如果你只是去度假两周，你会想“我不一定想花25小时或无论多少时间，只在这一段旅程上”。而我认为当你有一段延长的离家时间时，旅程本身就成了体验的一部分，不是吗？就像我回想起我在墨西哥城机场试图在商店门口睡觉的那一天，当时整个机场因为
terrible weather. And at the time, it was horrendous. It's quite funny to look back on. It's quite the story, right? And then I've never felt so tight. At that time, I've a parent now, so I felt tired since. But I've never felt so tired as the next day when we finally managed to blag our way onto a flight. We were told we wouldn't get on this one, but we went in and we just checked in and they let us on and we were like, oh my God, just carry on walking. Go to the departure gate. And I sat on the plane. And before I buckled myself in, I don't remember. I was asleep by the time the takeoff went.
糟糕的天气而关闭。当时，那真是太可怕了。回想起来很有趣。这真是一个故事，对吧？而且我从未感到如此疲惫。那时，我现在是个家长了，所以我之后也感到过疲惫。但我从未像第二天我们终于设法混上一架飞机时那样感到疲惫。我们被告知我们上不了这一班，但我们进去了，我们只是办理了登机手续，他们让我们上了飞机，我们当时想，哦天哪，继续走。去登机口。我坐在飞机上。在我系好安全带之前，我不记得了。起飞时我已经睡着了。
As soon as I sat down and buckled in and had my neck pillow on, I was gone. So yeah, we left Mexico City Airport, but I don't know what happened really until Cancun. To Cancun woke me up. But yeah, like really awful journeys or even just really, you know, lovely journeys. Like I have to confess, I love, I don't know if I have any experience of them, but I love a sleeper train. I've done them in Thailand. I've done them in Morocco.
我一坐下系好安全带，戴上颈枕，我就睡着了。所以是的，我们离开了墨西哥城机场，但我真的不知道发生了什么，直到坎昆。到坎昆才把我叫醒。但是的，像非常糟糕的旅程，或者甚至只是非常可爱的旅程。我必须承认，我喜欢，我不知道我是否有任何经验，但我喜欢卧铺火车。我在泰国坐过。我在摩洛哥坐过。
I've done them in India. And again, like, you could fly or you could go somewhere a bit more expensive. You could have a better, well, the class of travel. But the people I've met there and just, I don't know, it's the romance of being on a sleeper train. Like, yes, you are a bit vulnerable. Yes, you'd have to padlock your bag to the rails. But it's just amazing.
我在印度坐过。而且再一次，你可以坐飞机，或者你可以去一个稍微贵一点的地方。你可以有更好的旅行等级。但我遇到的人，我不知道，这是一种在卧铺火车上的浪漫。就像，是的，你有点脆弱。是的，你必须把包锁在栏杆上。但这太神奇了。
And I was recently looking at, I think, France, you think you can do a sleeper train from the UK to France and beyond. And I thought, oh, this would be a really nice grown-up way of me and the girl that I went travelling with doing this together because my husband would not be up for that. But the journeys are really part of it, I think. Yeah, absolutely. Sleeper train is something I've never done. but we would both love to do it. I've definitely been on plenty of coaches, etc., to go through the night,
我最近在看，我想是法国，你认为你可以从英国坐卧铺火车到法国及更远的地方。我想，哦，这对我来说和那个我一起旅行的女孩一起做这件事会是一种非常好的成熟方式，因为我丈夫不会同意那样做。但我认为旅程确实是其中的一部分。是的，绝对。卧铺火车是我从未做过的事情，但我们俩都会很乐意去做。我绝对坐过很多长途汽车等，通宵行驶，
and, as you say, some bus journeys, 18 hours plus and, you know, a bit of sore bum syndrome by the end of it, but you look back on them so fondly. Like you say, when you've got that extended time, I mean, the bus journeys or whatever, they take you to the most random places. You might end up at a little bus stop,
而且，正如你所说，一些巴士旅程，18小时以上，你知道，最后有点屁股酸痛综合症，但你回想起它们时会非常怀念。就像你说的，当你有了那段延长的空闲时间，我的意思是，巴士旅程或任何东西，它们把你带到最随机的地方。你可能会在一个小巴士站结束行程，
and, you know, they're serving beans and rice and plantain or whatever, and there's like a thousand people there, it feels like you can barely move. and at the time it's very stressful and sweaty and you're exhausted. But those are the moments he sort of looked back on almost more than all the things you predicted that were going to be amazing. Absolutely. I remember it was so hot on a train in Morocco and it was so busy and there was no space for us to sit down.
而且，你知道，他们供应豆子、米饭和大蕉或任何东西，那里有一千个人，感觉你几乎无法移动。当时这非常紧张、闷热，你精疲力竭。但那些是你回想起来几乎比你预想会很棒的所有事情还要多的时刻。绝对。我记得在摩洛哥的一列火车上，天气太热了，而且非常拥挤，我们没有空间坐下。
And so it was me with my friend Ruth at the time and then just a random chap that we'd ended up stood with and we were wedged in with our backpacks on our back and our day packs on our front standing for hours in the sweltering train by a toilet that stunk. Like it was a really difficult experience. But then as soon as the train cleared and we ended up sitting in a carriage and it was just, you know, all of that melts away. And even though we stunk, like it was really magical. Like, you know, stinky and magical. Like it's a good combo, right? I think we just, we do learn so much about ourselves and how to connect with others as well. Would you agree? Yeah, absolutely. Like traveling itself is all about
所以当时是我和我的朋友露丝，还有一个我们最终站在一起的随机小伙子，我们背着背包，前面挂着日用包，在闷热的火车上站在厕所旁边几个小时，那厕所臭气熏天。那真是一次非常困难的经历。但一旦火车空了，我们最终坐在车厢里，你知道，所有这些都融化了。即使我们很臭，那也真的很神奇。就像，你知道，又臭又神奇。这是一个很好的组合，对吧？我想我们确实学到了很多关于我们自己以及如何与他人建立联系的知识。你同意吗？是的，绝对。旅行本身就是关于
experience a new thing, experience in new cultures and people and places. And whether that's doing something like work away in a far off country or if you've grown up in the countryside, going to the city for the first time, you know, I was thinking about this the other day before filming and thinking about how travel might seem inaccessible to some people, but thinking about how lucky we are in the UK to have so many diverse cultures and so many different parts of the country that have, you know, different ways of life and different types of people living there. And it doesn't have to be about a flight abroad and spending money on accommodation for a few weeks. You know, you could go from a southern English city to the north
体验新事物，体验新文化、人和地方。无论是在遥远的国家做像Workaway这样的事情，还是如果你在乡村长大，第一次去城市，你知道，我在拍摄前几天还在想这个，思考旅行对某些人来说可能看起来遥不可及，但想到我们在英国是多么幸运，拥有如此多样的文化和国家中如此多不同的部分，它们有不同的生活方式和生活在那里的人。这不一定非要是出国飞行和花钱住几周的住宿。你知道，你可以从英格兰南部的一个城市去苏格兰北部
of Scotland to experience life in the highlands as a croftor or whatever. And the opportunities are all there at home and you can do that on a weekend away from work or but yeah i think the um one of the things we love about the work away experience is you know there's plenty of them in the UK all across europe it's a global platform and it means that you get to spend more time in perhaps a location that's actually off the beaten track a little bit and you get to spend that time with a family who lives there whether they're from the country or immigrated there and actually get a a real taste of daily life in that context so you really get a much deeper appreciation for it because you have to settle into their rhythm their way of doing things and working alongside them as well so it's a really special
去体验作为农场主的生活或任何东西。机会都在家里，你可以在周末从工作中抽身，或者，是的，我认为我们喜欢Workaway体验的原因之一是，你知道，在英国、整个欧洲有很多这样的机会，这是一个全球平台，这意味着你可以在一个稍微偏僻一点的地方花更多时间，你可以和住在那里的一家人一起度过那段时间，无论他们是来自那个国家还是移民到那里，并真正体验那种环境下的日常生活，所以你确实对它有了更深刻的欣赏，因为你必须适应他们的节奏、他们的做事方式以及与他们并肩工作，所以这是一种非常特别的
way to travel and that's one of the reasons we love it so much it's not just the fact that it saves us loads of money which is of course really convenient as well but yeah it's something i think i'll continue to do for the rest of my life even if it's on shorter trips you know spend two weeks somewhere yeah i certainly continued to do that so even once i was back in the UK, I would go on. It helped that my friend was a trainee teacher and then she was a qualified teacher. So I was single for a lot of that time after I graduated. And so we would go off and spend the summers together. So it helped that she had more time. And yeah, that's kind of one of the reasons I was able to travel so extensively. But yeah, you make a really good point about
旅行方式，这也是我们如此喜欢它的原因之一。这不仅仅是因为它为我们节省了大量金钱，当然这也很方便，但是的，我认为我余生都会继续这样做，即使是在较短的旅行中，你知道，在某个地方待两周。是的，我当然继续那样做，所以即使我回到英国后，我也会去。我的朋友是一名实习教师，然后她成为了一名合格的教师，这很有帮助。所以我毕业后很长一段时间都是单身。所以我们会一起去度过夏天。所以她有更多时间很有帮助。而且是的，这就是我能够如此广泛旅行的原因之一。但是的，你提出了一个很好的观点，关于
it doesn't need to be expensive. It also doesn't need to be, you know, international. So I was having to go down to work to London recently and I was looking at different accommodation options and I was travelling by myself and it was going to be night time that I was around so I did choose a slightly nicer hotel room because I need to be I need to be feeling safe in Kings Cross but it was interesting that I could have got hostel rooms from £17 and I used to be all over hostels so when I was travelling it was other hostels or guest houses and yeah like you could take a weekend so you could finish work on a Friday, choose to go, I don't know, to West Wales and, you know, go and stay wherever you want to stay for not that much money and then come
它不需要很昂贵。它也不需要是国际性的。所以我最近不得不去伦敦工作，我正在寻找不同的住宿选择，我是独自旅行，我周围会是晚上，所以我确实选择了一个稍微好一点的酒店房间，因为我需要在国王十字车站感到安全，但有趣的是，我可以以17英镑的价格买到青年旅舍的房间，我过去经常住青年旅舍，所以当我旅行时，要么是青年旅舍要么是旅馆，而且是的，你可以利用一个周末，所以你可以在周五下班，选择去，我不知道，去西威尔士，然后，你知道，去你想住的地方住，不用花太多钱，然后回来
back to work and go to work on Monday. It doesn't need to be an extended period of time. You still can have travel. And interestingly, I don't know if you know, but there's a, there's a Caledonian sleeper service that goes from Houston to Scotland. So if you wanted to experience It's a probably quite much more expensive sleeper train. People could be like, oh, I could do that. But it doesn't need to cost a fortune. And I appreciate that if you are really struggling to make ends meet or you have mouths to feed or parents to look after, for example,
去工作，周一去上班。它不需要是一段很长的时间。你仍然可以旅行。有趣的是，我不知道你是否知道，有一趟从尤斯顿到苏格兰的喀里多尼亚卧铺服务。所以如果你想体验，那可能是一趟贵得多的卧铺火车。人们可能会说，哦，我可以那样做。但它不需要花费一大笔钱。而且我很感激，如果你真的在努力维持生计，或者你有孩子要养，或者有父母要照顾，例如，
that that is going to impact on your decisions. But, yeah, we recognise that not everyone has six months a year to do this. So I hope this is not coming across as too privileged an episode because I definitely felt like I did it on a shoestring, but equally, equally well, I had a home to return to that my parents both lived in, so I do, I do recognise that. Yeah, absolutely. And like you say, the privilege of being able to travel is not just financial, because we've always done it on a shoestring as well. But like you say, it can be the privilege of time, the privilege of a safe house to come back to for a month while you find
那会影响你的决定。所以，是的，我们认识到并不是每个人都有六个月或一年的时间来做这件事。所以我希望这期节目听起来不会太有特权感，因为我绝对觉得我是靠微薄的预算做到的，但同样地，我也确实有一个父母都住的家可以回去，所以我确实认识到这一点。是的，绝对。就像你说的，能够旅行的特权不仅仅是经济上的，因为我们也总是靠微薄的预算做到的。但就像你说的，它可以是时间的特权，有一个安全的家可以回去住一个月，同时你寻找
a job and some accommodation. So I do appreciate that. And also, I think when you go to certain other countries as well, appreciating the privilege that you maybe have of being able to afford to go to a country where perhaps a lot of people can't afford to leave or to go elsewhere. And at least acknowledging that and, you know, bringing that into conversations or interactions that you have. We've all seen those people on holidays seem to be splashing the cash and talking about how cheap it is there. I'm number one experience in Croatia. We're at a bar and some people are kind of saying this to the chef at the bar saying, oh, we can't believe how incredibly cheap it is here. They were from England and he said, well, it's not
工作和住宿。所以我确实很感激。而且，我认为当你去某些其他国家时，也要欣赏你可能拥有的特权，即能够负担得起去一个许多人可能负担不起离开或去其他地方的国家。至少承认这一点，并将其带入你进行的对话或互动中。我们都见过那些在度假时似乎在挥霍金钱并谈论那里有多便宜的人。我在克罗地亚的一次经历。我们在酒吧，有些人对酒吧的厨师说，哦，我们不敢相信这里有多便宜。他们来自英国，他说，嗯，对我来说并不
cheap for me, you know, and quite affrontly by that, because it was sort of rubbing it in his face that they could go there and have the time of their lives for him next to no money to them. So, yeah, it's always worth it. I hope they tipped him after, after mortally offending him. But I think people just don't, don't consider, do they? Like, you know, we can all think about wealthy American tourists and how brash that might seem at times. But we can also be quite similar but maybe not quite so overtly. Yeah, you can make a really good point. And I think my dad died in 2017 and I definitely thought had he died when I was younger, I don't know if I'd have felt as confident to go off around the world. You know what I mean, Ben? Because he was such a
便宜，你知道，他对此感到相当冒犯，因为这就像是在他脸上炫耀他们可以去那里，花很少的钱就能享受生活，而对他来说却不是。所以，是的，这总是值得的。我希望他们在严重冒犯他之后给了他小费。但我认为人们只是不考虑，对吧？就像，你知道，我们都可以想到富有的美国游客，以及这有时看起来多么粗鲁。但我们也可能非常相似，只是可能没有那么明显。是的，你提出了一个很好的观点。而且我认为我父亲在2017年去世了，我绝对想过，如果他在我年轻时去世，我不知道我是否会有信心去环游世界。你知道我的意思吗，本？因为他对我来说是一个
stabilising factor for me and knowing that I could call, you know, and did call, you know, from Australian, but like, hi, Daddy, you know, was lovely. And knowing that he, he would always pick up the phone, no matter what time it was, like, and he was always happy to hear from me. And, yeah, that's a really lovely, a lovely kind of relationship to have, someone that's never going to, I don't know, like, you're never going to be in trouble, which is really nice. Whereas, yeah, I think not everyone would have that experience. And yeah, I do feel lucky that my parents were healthy when I was in my intrepid days. And so it did free me up. up to go off and scratch my own itches so to speak yeah totally and i feel exactly the same you know
稳定的因素，知道我可以打电话，而且确实打了，你知道，从澳大利亚，但像，嗨，爸爸，你知道，那很可爱。而且知道他总是会接电话，无论什么时候，而且他总是很高兴听到我的声音。而且，是的，那是一种非常可爱的关系，有人永远不会，我不知道，就像，你永远不会有麻烦，这真的很好。然而，是的，我认为并不是每个人都会有那种经历。而且，是的，我确实感到幸运，我的父母在我勇敢的日子里很健康。所以它确实让我自由了，
when we went off to sort of central south america in 2017 and again now um i also just know like we were saying before that i don't feel any external pressure from family to get on with my career so i sort of have that comfort of even not just that i can go back to them but know that whilst i'm traveling they're in their minds they're just saying yeah go for it do it do whatever it's for you So yeah, I totally appreciate that if I didn't have that feeling, maybe I would feel a little bit differently about, you know, wandering off into my late 20s and now 30s, still meandering across the world without necessarily having a set career path when I get back. Absolutely. And I often think I just didn't know how lucky I was at the time. I hadn't really faced much adversity. I have to confess by the time I got to late 2020. 21, kind of early 22, how lucky I was just to be able to sit in a lovely bar in Kolanta in Thailand and I ended up spending, I think, a whole week, maybe slightly longer in this
去追求我自己的渴望。是的，完全一样，你知道，当我们2017年去中南美洲时，现在又一次，我也只是知道，就像我们之前说的，我没有感受到来自家人的任何外部压力去推进我的职业生涯，所以我有一种安慰，不仅是我可以回到他们身边，而且知道当我在旅行时，在他们的心中，他们只是说“是的，去吧，做吧，做任何对你来说合适的事”。所以，是的，我完全理解，如果我没有那种感觉，也许我会对在20多岁末和现在30岁时，仍然在世界各地漫游，而回到家时没有固定的职业道路，感觉有点不同。绝对。而且我经常想，我当时只是不知道自己有多幸运。我并没有真正面对太多的逆境。我必须承认，到2020年晚些时候，21岁，22岁出头时，我能坐在泰国兰塔岛一家可爱的酒吧里是多么幸运，我最终花了，我想，整整一周，也许稍微长一点的时间在这个
one resort because it was so lovely and just being able to sit in a hammock and at the time we were listening to, they kept playing a Jack Johnson album and I'd never heard a Jack Johnson before. It was really weird when he became a big thing in the UK because I was like, but he's mine. I determined him first. And it was really, yeah, really just very relaxed, sitting in a hammock, watching the sea. And, you know, I don't know if I've ever quite been so carefree since, really. It's really, really lucky. Yeah. Yeah, the first time we did a big trip to South America, and it might be helpful for some listeners to know. I, I, I, I spent a lot of my teenage years struggling with anxiety and social anxiety was a big part of that
度假村，因为它太可爱了，能够坐在吊床上，当时我们正在听，他们一直在播放杰克·约翰逊的专辑，我以前从未听过杰克·约翰逊。当他在英国变得大红大紫时，这真的很奇怪，因为我想，但他是我先发现的。而且这真的很放松，坐在吊床上，看着大海。而且，你知道，我不知道从那以后我是否真的那么无忧无虑过，真的。真的很幸运。是的，我们第一次去南美洲进行大旅行，这对一些听众来说可能很有帮助。我，我，我，我花了很多青少年时期与焦虑作斗争，社交焦虑是其中的很大一部分
for me. And I was always quite social, but also inside I was really struggling. And I actually did a course of CBT prior to going to South America. And then going into that environment where I was forced to be social. Yes, I had my partner with me, but I was in an environment with lots of people I didn't really have a choice. And it was hugely beneficial for me to take what I'd learned during that CBT and then, you know, have almost that forced exposure once I was ready for it. And just let go a little bit more. And yeah, it did wonders for me and perhaps is one of the big reasons that I've continued to travel ever since. So it was quite a transformative six, seven months for quite a lot of different reasons. And again, having that time to travel after
对我来说。我一直很善于社交，但在内心深处我真的很挣扎。在去南美之前，我实际上做了一个CBT疗程。然后进入那个我被迫社交的环境。是的，我有我的伴侣陪着我，但我处于一个有很多我没有选择的人的环境中。对我来说，利用我在CBT期间学到的东西，然后，你知道，一旦我准备好了，就有那种被迫的暴露，是非常有益的。只是稍微放手一点。而且，是的，它对我产生了奇效，也许是我从那以后继续旅行的一大原因。所以那六、七个月对很多不同的原因来说都是变革性的。而且再一次，在做完那个之后有时间去旅行，留给了我很多空间去反思，你知道，活在外面而不是活在里面，并且第一次读了很多书。所以这真的很特别。而且，是的，就像我说的，这可能就是驱使我继续这样做的原因，因为每次我这样做，我学到的就越多，而且每次你进入一个新的环境，你都会多推自己一把。很高兴听到你克服了那些挣扎，而且你能够继续过上如此自由的生活，你知道，因为你能够接受那种治疗和疗法。所以，是的，很高兴听到这些。而且它也让我想到，其实当我还是个实习生时，我记得我真的
having done that left me with a lot of space to be reflective and, you know, live out here instead of in here and do a lot of reading for the first time. So it was really special. And yeah, like I say, it probably is what drives me to keep doing it, because every time I do it, I learn more and more and you push yourself a little bit extra every time you go into a new environment. So pleased to hear you have become those struggles, but also that you've been able to go on and live such a free existence, you know, because you've been able to have that treatment and that therapy. So yeah, very pleased to hear that. And it also kind of made me think about actually when I, when I was even a trainee, I remember I was really
其实仍然向人们推荐，如果他们可以的话，如果他们在一个实习计划中，他们有六个月的实习，六个月的实习，六个月的实习，你知道，紧随其后，你尝试在实习的最后一周休年假，也许去度假或去做点什么，然后我的大学通常会在那之后附加一些学习假，所以我会在实习的最后一周休假，然后回家去学习，但那真正让我自由去做的是去像和朋友在纽基冲浪之类的事情，但那是基于英国的短途旅行，因为当时钱不是太充裕，而且仍然有一种非常好的方式去期待某件事。所以对我来说，这非常关键。如果你知道你预订了假期，它可以帮助任何愉快的事情，真的。它不一定非要是假期，对吧？但它能帮助你度过一些棘手的日子。你知道，我必须熬过这一天
recommend actually still to people that if they can, if they're on a place, if they're on a trainee scheme where they have six-month placement, six-month placement, six-month placement, you know, followed by, followed by, that you try and take the last week of annual leave of your placement and maybe have a holiday or go and do something and then often my uni would kind of bolt on some study leave at the end of that so I would take the last week of placement as leave and then would be home to come and do the study right but what what that really freed me up to do was to go and do things like surfing in Newkey with my friends and things like but short trips that
然后我就可以做这个了。而且我认为因为实习结束，你知道，以及随之而来的一切，比如实习评估，在你开始新事物之前关闭你生命中的那段时期，对我来说，旅行一直是一种非常可爱的方式来做到这一点，并自然地帮助你从一件事过渡到另一件事。所以如果人们问，我该如何思考
were UK based because money was not too abundant at that time and still have just really nice way of looking forward to something. So that for me is really key. If you know you've got a holiday booked, it can help anything enjoyable really. It doesn't have to be a holiday, is it? But it helps you with some of the trickier days. You know, I've got to get through this
我们当时住在英国，因为那时候手头并不宽裕，但依然有一种非常美好的方式去期待某件事。所以对我来说，这真的很关键。如果你知道自己预订了假期，它真的能让任何事情变得令人愉快。不一定非得是假期，对吧？但它能帮你度过一些比较难熬的日子。你知道，我得熬过这段时间
and then I can do this. And I think because of the end of placement, you know, and all that that entails, like end of placement of you and kind of shut down that period of your life before you then go and start something new, for me, travel was always a really lovely, a lovely way to do that and to kind of naturally help you bridge from one thing to another. So if people are like, how can I maybe think
然后我就可以做这件事了。我觉得因为实习结束，以及随之而来的一切，比如实习结束，你会在开启新生活之前，自然地结束人生的那个阶段。对我来说，旅行一直是一种非常美妙的方式，可以自然地帮助你从一件事过渡到另一件事。所以如果有人问，我该怎么去思考
about still having a traditional route, but include more travel, that's what I would, that's what I would recommend. Yeah, totally, like you say, that's something I've been thinking about as well. It's having that thing to look forward to, like you say, gets you through the harder days and you know that you can give yourself a little bit of time where you're not going to have that cognitive load. So you can still live in the stress. Maybe it can be useful sometimes, but it's great to know that you're going to have that little bit of relief. And one of the big things for travelling for me is being able to get out into nature as well, you know, getting out hiking, things like that. It's a huge hobby of night at home.
关于仍然保留传统路线，但增加更多旅行，这就是我会推荐的。是的，完全同意，就像你说的，这也是我一直在思考的事情。拥有一个值得期待的目标，正如你所说，能帮你度过艰难的日子，你知道你可以给自己留出一点时间，不必承受那种认知负荷。所以你仍然可以生活在压力中。也许这有时是有用的，但知道自己会得到一点解脱的感觉真好。对我来说，旅行的一大意义在于能够走进大自然，比如去徒步旅行之类的。这在家里是我的一大爱好。
So again, it doesn't have to be getting too far away from home, but if you can get out into a new environment, you know, a set of hells you you've never been into before. It's still something new, getting physical exercise, and then you get all of the well-documented benefits of nature exposure and connectedness to nature, et cetera, as well. And I always try to make that a bit of a centrepiece of my travel because it just makes me look forward to it even more as well. Yeah, and you feel like you really then know something about the country
所以同样，不必离家太远，但如果你能进入一个新的环境，比如去一些你从未去过的山丘。这仍然是新鲜的体验，进行体育锻炼，然后你还能获得大自然接触和与自然连接等带来的所有有据可查的好处。我总是尽量把这一点作为我旅行的核心，因为它让我更加期待旅行。是的，而且你会觉得你真的了解那个国家，
that you've visited if you've kind of gone and appreciated some of the landscape and, you know, some of the things that local people would see as well rather than just the monuments. So I have been to a fair few monuments and I have to say I was quite disappointed by the Sydney Opera House. In real life, I thought it was strangely underwhelming and kind of, I'd imagined it was going to be like this really vibrant white gleaning thing. And it looked a bit like a sort of brown armadillo when I saw it, sort of goldish colour. And I was like, this is not what I expected. But something that did blow me away was the Taj Mahal. That really was breathtaking, I have to say.
如果你去过并欣赏过那里的风景，以及当地人会看到的一些东西，而不仅仅是纪念碑。我去过不少纪念碑，我必须说我对悉尼歌剧院感到相当失望。在现实生活中，我觉得它出奇地平淡，我原以为它会是一个非常鲜艳、闪闪发光的白色建筑。但我看到它时，它看起来有点像一只棕色的犰狳，颜色有点发金。我当时想，这和我预想的不一样。但有一件事确实让我惊叹，那就是泰姬陵。我必须说，那真的很壮观。
And I think because I'd already seen and been underwhelmed by the Sydney Opera House, I was expecting that I would be similarly underwhelmed by the Taj Mahal, but I really wasn't like that. That is magnificent. Are there any sites or things or countries that are on your bucket list, Ben? I mean, Chile was one of them, hence why I'm here just now, and so was Canada. I would love to get to Peru. I mean, I don't know necessarily why I've always had a bit of an affinity for sexual in South America.
我想是因为我已经看过悉尼歌剧院并感到失望，所以我以为我对泰姬陵也会有同样的失望感，但事实并非如此。那真是太宏伟了。本，你的愿望清单上有什么地方或事情吗？我的意思是，智利是其中之一，所以我现在才在这里，加拿大也是。我很想去秘鲁。我的意思是，我不知道为什么我一直对南美洲有一种亲近感。
It's why I went there in 2017 and why I've come back now. There's something about the sort of social nature of the culture, perhaps the food as well, that just seems to really chime with me. But yeah, I love hiking and I love the mountains. things like the Andes or I would love to get to Nepal and see the Himalayas as well. That would be, yeah, that's probably the next big bucket list item. But I think that will be quite a few years away after this trip. Yeah, one of my friends who I was on training with,
这就是我2017年去那里的原因，也是我现在又回来的原因。那种文化的社交属性，也许还有食物，似乎真的与我产生了共鸣。但是，是的，我喜欢徒步旅行，我喜欢山脉。像安第斯山脉这样的地方，或者我很想去尼泊尔看看喜马拉雅山。那可能是下一个大愿望清单项目。但我认为那将是这次旅行之后几年后的事了。是的，我和我一起参加培训的朋友之一，
she was also similarly intrepid and she went and stayed in Nepal for a bit. I got back from travelling in India on a Friday. day, I think. My leaving party was in Milton Keynes on the Saturday. I moved house on the Sunday from Milton Keynes to Coventry and I started my doctorate on the Monday. I was not messing around. I was like ringing every little last bit out of that trip that I could. So yeah, I arrived on training very tanned, very skinny because I'd been vegetarian. when I was in India. Very happy, very excited and ready to learn. So yeah, like just really, really think about what is going to light you up, is what I would say, to our audience. So
她也同样勇敢，她在尼泊尔待了一段时间。我想我是周五从印度旅行回来。我的欢送会在周六在米尔顿凯恩斯举行。周日我从米尔顿凯恩斯搬家到考文垂，周一开始攻读博士学位。我可没闲着。我当时想从那次旅行中榨取最后一点价值。所以，是的，我带着非常健康的肤色、非常瘦的身材参加了培训，因为我在印度时一直是素食主义者。非常快乐，非常兴奋，准备好学习了。所以，是的，真的，真的要考虑什么会点亮你的生活，这就是我想对我们的听众说的，所以
don't think about what someone else's ideal path would be. Really think about what living to your values would look like. And if you gave yourself a mission to do that, it could be transformational is what I would say, Ben. Yeah, absolutely. And on this trip, you know, for a little bit now, I've been, I always say 99% sure that I wanted to be a clinical psychologist because I've been kind of sure of other things in the past, whether it's currently related or not, and then change your mind and almost felt a little bit of guilt and shame around that. So I've given myself that little 1% space ever since I decided to follow this path so that if I do change my mind at any point, then I know I've already
不要去想别人理想的道路是什么。真正去思考活出你的价值观是什么样子的。如果你给自己设定一个任务去实现它，那将是变革性的，本。是的，绝对是。在这次旅行中，你知道，有一段时间了，我一直说我有99%的把握我想成为一名临床心理学家，因为我过去对其他事情也曾有过某种确定，无论是否与职业相关，然后又改变了主意，几乎为此感到一点内疚和羞耻。所以我自从决定走这条路以来，就给了自己那1%的空间，这样如果我在任何时候改变主意，我就知道我已经
the lift room to be okay with that and accept that, you know, it's okay to change your mind. I still feel 99, I'm going to say 0.9% sure now, but doing other things I enjoy on this trip like gardening the work and outdoors work, you know, has allowed me to reflect on that and go, yes, I do really enjoy this and I'm enjoying having some time away from my career and studying. But I'm definitely sure I still want to go back and do that. I'm loving this, but it's given me that little bit of time space to have a little bit of clarity on that goal. And it's been very reaffirming for me
有余地去接受它，并承认改变主意是可以的。我现在仍然觉得有99.9%的把握，但在这次旅行中做我喜欢的其他事情，比如园艺工作和户外工作，让我反思并意识到，是的，我确实非常喜欢这些，我也很享受从职业和学习中抽身出来的时间。但我绝对确定我仍然想回去做那件事。我喜欢现在的状态，但这给了我一点时间和空间来理清那个目标。这对我来说是非常肯定的，
that I am on the path that's going to be right for me. But I'm still going to give myself 0.1% space, just in case. Yeah, and actually, I think you will really enjoy an episode that I've got coming up. I think it's just before this episode, if not two before this episode, with, no, it's after this episode. It's after this one.
我确实走在适合我的道路上。但我仍然会给自己留出0.1%的空间，以防万一。是的，实际上，我想你会非常喜欢我即将推出的一集。我想就在这一集之前，如果不是两集之前的话，和，不，是在这一集之后。是在这一集之后。
It's Dr. Matt Slavin. in and I think it's episode 112 and we're talking about the kind of what it's like to have a human brain and kind of the evolution of being human and we talk about kind of timelines and self-actualization and stuff in that and I think that will really resonate with you so if anyone else is interested in what in that section look out for that episode as well then thank you so much for your time is there only thing we haven't covered that you think that we should not necessarily no I mean We could talk on and on and on. I'm sure there's plenty of things that might be of interest to us and interest to others, but there are nothing in particular things. Okay, thank you. And I know that I'm going to try and dig out some of my travelling photos, and you're going to send across some of yours.
是马特·斯莱文博士，我想是第112集，我们谈论的是拥有人类大脑是什么感觉，以及人类进化的过程，我们谈论了时间线和自我实现之类的东西，我认为这会引起你的共鸣，所以如果还有其他人对那部分感兴趣，也请关注那一集。本，非常感谢你的时间，有什么我们没涵盖到但你认为我们应该谈谈的吗？不一定，不。我的意思是，我们可以一直谈下去。我相信有很多事情可能对我们和他人感兴趣，但没有什么特别的事情。好的，谢谢。我知道我会试着找出我的一些旅行照片，你也会发给我一些你的。
So if people are watching on YouTube, there's maybe a chance to see some kind of nice inspirational travel shots. Mine are probably all on actual film camera, so I'm going to have to try and rummage in the loft for that one, I think. Amazing. Thank you so much for. your time ban and sharing your wisdom and your precious time when you're away with our audience as well yes thank you very much for having me on it's been a pleasure oh you're so welcome thank you again
所以如果人们在YouTube上观看，也许有机会看到一些不错的励志旅行照片。我的照片可能都在胶片相机里，所以我得去阁楼里翻找一下。太棒了。非常感谢你的时间，本，感谢你在旅行期间与我们的听众分享你的智慧和宝贵时间。是的，非常感谢邀请我，这是一种荣幸。哦，不客气，再次感谢。
oh thank you so much again for ben's time in speaking to us from his actual travels in chili how marvellous i would love to know in the comments on youtube or you can drop me a question or a comment on spotify if you're on apple you can rate and review the show and I'd be so grateful if you did. This all came about because Ben had requested his free psychology success guide where he had let me know his most pressing concern in his career journey. And you can do the same as well and I will send you an actual email from my actual fingers sitting on my sofa usually responding to make you some bespoke guidance. And you get the great success guide as well. So why not come along to www.wespiring hyphen
哦，再次非常感谢本在智利旅行期间与我们交谈，真是太棒了。我很想在YouTube的评论区知道，或者如果你在Spotify上，你可以给我提问或评论，如果你在Apple上，你可以给节目评分和评论，如果你这样做，我会非常感激。这一切的起因是本索取了他的免费心理学成功指南，他在指南中让我知道了他职业生涯中最紧迫的担忧。你也可以这样做，我会用我坐在沙发上的手指亲自给你发一封电子邮件，通常会回复你一些定制的指导。你也会得到很棒的成功指南。所以为什么不来访问 www.wespiring-psychologist.co.org
psychologist.co.org scroll right to the bottom of that first page you will get to and you will see the free psychology success guide. Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you are interested in the stories of other aspiring psychologists, please do check out the clinical Psychologist Collective and the aspiring Psychologist Collective books. Thank you for being a watcher or a listener to this content. There is brand new kid on the block and it is a way to subscribe to my channel or for that matter to the podcast. So you can pay to be a subscriber or you get some sneak peek behind the scenes, kind of thinking about each of the episodes unfolding. You get some thoughts from me in the planning stages of the episode, you get some thoughts
滚动到你到达的第一页的最底部，你就会看到免费的心理学成功指南。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你对其他有抱负的心理学家的故事感兴趣，请查看《临床心理学家集体》和《有抱负的心理学家集体》书籍。感谢你成为这些内容的观看者或听者。这里有一个新成员，它是订阅我的频道或播客的一种方式。所以你可以付费成为订阅者，或者你会得到一些幕后花絮，思考每一集的发展过程。你会得到我在策划阶段的一些想法，你会得到
before I record the episode, and you get some thoughts afterwards. And you get to see other areas of my house as well. There's no minimum term, I don't think, but I'm yet to actually sort that out by the time. But by the time this episode lands, wherever you're watching or listening, this service will be available on Spotify, on Apple and on YouTube. So do check that out. And that is all money that goes towards helping me provide this content, which does cost me many hundred pounds a month. So, yeah, if you fancy just, it's a bit like a Patreon, but you're getting a little bit of an extra thank you. You're getting an exclusive subscriber.
我在录制这一集之前的一些想法，以及之后的一些想法。你还可以看到我房子的其他区域。我不认为有最低期限，但我还没来得及整理好。但当这一集发布时，无论你在哪里观看或收听，这项服务都将在Spotify、Apple和YouTube上提供。所以一定要去看看。所有这些钱都将用于帮助我提供这些内容，这确实每月花费我几百英镑。所以，是的，如果你想，这有点像Patreon，但你会得到一点额外的感谢。你会得到独家的订阅者。
content so yeah i hope you'll really love it and i've welcome any feedback if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that's your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there
内容，所以是的，我希望你会非常喜欢它，如果你们想成为一名心理学家，就让这个播客成为你的指南，这是你的伙伴，你将走上获得资格的道路，这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我的名字是亚娜，我是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，这让我感到惊讶，
and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名心理学家。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。